I got to ask you Hans and Franz appears
to be back with a vengeance you're doing
these State Farm ads I'm seeing on TV
they're very good they're funny yeah
Dana Carvey and I we played Hans and
Franz you know we find the good lemon
gambled them into submission
yeah and in State Farm is uh is using us
to do these commercials Aaron Rodgers
the quarterback from Green Bay you know
20 I was right Iran starting out live
when you guys were doing Hans and Franz
and I remembered the time that Swartz
nagger came and I didn't realize this is
the time but but it was the first time
that that you guys had sort of met him
and that's right and it was sort of a
tense situation was very tense because
we were making fun of them you know and
we thought doesn't he know we're making
fun of them right is he that dumb yeah
does he get home before he knows it so
you know they came in that we figured
he's coming on a show to kill us you
thought because you were a little
worried you thought I remembered he he
the way I remembered it is you guys were
waiting for him to show up and you were
dressed as Hans and Franz we were you
were dreading him coming and then they
got us they said Arnold's in the
dressing room he wants to talk to you
guys and we were like two kids going to
the principal's office
you know we're blaming each other you
came up and I know I didn't you did I
said no gap between the teeth I said no
I accent he's gonna know it's him and we
get to the dressing room and his name's
on the door his name so long I went onto
the wall a little bit do you know and we
open up the door and it was full of
cigar smoke in there and we could see
him sitting across the room on a chair
and and he had a big cigar on one hand
and he had the script we wrote on the
other hand I'll never forget this he
looked up through the cigar smoke to us
and he goes hello fellas now how am I
supposed to do the accent
[Laughter]
you know you know better than anybody
because we wrote a movie about Hans in
France it never got made but Wright was
co-starring in and co-producing it was
called Hans and Franz the girly men
dilemma I don't remember the title I
remember that Robert Smigel and I helped
you and Dana to try and turn it into a
music yeah it was becoming we tried to
turn Hans and Franz into a musical we
tried for a couple of weeks and I don't
remember what happened what happened was
we finished writing it and he was gonna
co-star and co-produce it and then it
didn't happen he got like cold feet you
know I guess because if something else
came out where he parried it himself but
you know in the beginning I was like
we're all safe he goes yeah this is
gonna be fantastic
you know you can't go wrong with the
Hans and Franz you know you guys do
something else and then you know a
couple months go by we call his office
Aya's Arnold there no he's not around he
stepped away from his desk okay okay and
then you hear in the background did he I
hope yet is it need a little coffee
which one is it whose Franzen whose ha
but you know he answered was like no
he's not here he stepped away from his -
yeah
this is Marcia
how many cameras do you have here it's
like clearly not enough let's see let's
touch them out
let's go to one to six
oh alright well whatever our director
doesn't know which one is where you
going numerical how much of this is
paparazzi on weeds on weeds you played
someone who's smoking a lot of pot yeah
I know and and and I'm just curious what
about you in real life the real Kevin
Nealon does no no I don't smoke about I
had a pot brownie once and I'm telling
never again you're not supposed to eat
the whole pot brownie suppose the whole
thing ate the whole thing because I like
the brownie mm-hmm you know but you're
supposed to have one sixtieth of it I
was told and next two days I'm out like
this right well I finally came around I
thought that's it no more sugar for me
[Applause]
you